today on the matt walsh show joe biden
continues to fall apart mentally and
physically this is the consequence of
putting a senile man in the white house
is it time to talk seriously about
putting an upper age limit on the
presidency
why haven't we talked seriously about
that already also five headlines
including
a plan in oakland to give 500 monthly
checks to
to poor families except the white ones
another example of systemic racism
against whites
and sesame street gets racially woke
plus a new mask
that you can wear while you eat unless
you have self-respect and dignity that
is in which case of course you won't
wear it
in our daily cancellation i will once
again have to cancel the people who are
trying to cancel me a reverse
cancellation
always a thrill all that much more today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
as it turns out it may not have been the
best idea to put a 78 year old
dementia patient in the white house who
could have possibly predicted that well
anyone could have and many of us did
we've only just begun to experience the
consequences
of having a mentally and physically
unfit person as commander-in-chief
the embarrassing display during biden's
first press conference on thursday was
the latest embarrassment
that he has brought upon himself and
thus upon upon the country
and it certainly won't be the last the
media is of course
making things as easy as it can for our
senile president by posing questions
like and i'm not making this up
questions like are immigrants coming
here because you're such a good and
decent man
that is only a slight paraphrase here's
how it was actually phrased let's listen
thanks so much mr president you've said
over and over again
that immigrants shouldn't come to this
country right now this isn't the time to
come
that message is not being received
instead the perception of you
that got you elected as a moral decent
man is
the reason why a lot of immigrants are
coming to this country and entrusting
you with unaccompanied minors
how do you resolve that tension and
how are you choosing which families can
stay which can can go given the fact
that even though
with title 42 there are some families
that are staying and is there a timeline
for when
we won't be seeing these overcrowded
facilities with run by cpb
when it comes to unaccompanied minors
well look i guess i should be flattered
people are coming because i'm the nice
guy that's the reason why it's happening
that i'm a decent man or whoever's
phrased that you know that's why they're
coming because no biden's a good guy
yes mr president mr president mr
president follow-up question um
you uh it strikes me that you're a very
good-looking handsome man
thoughts thoughts on that
are media holding feet to the fire as
always
but their efforts couldn't save biden
from himself as he stumbled
mumbled bumbled his way through the
short exchange with his obedient press
corps
at one point the president claimed that
he came to the united states senate 120
years ago
let's listen to that with regard to the
filibuster i believe
we should go back to a position of the
filibuster that existed
just when i came to the united states
senate 120 years ago
and that is that now
that claim is closer to the truth than
it ought to be
i mean it wasn't 120 years ago but it
was not far
from that uh his math is still a little
bit off the mark though and that was far
from the most alarming incident
at another point the president began to
answer a question trailed off
into unintelligible rambling stopped
abruptly
and picked up with a new thought here's
what that sounded like
i'm going to say something outrageous i
have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done
in the united states senate so the best
way to get something done
if you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to anyway
i'm we're we're going to get a lot done
and if we have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about
okay um hang on
uh sorry
oh sing me miss kim
well that was outrageous he was right
about that now here's the transcript of
that moment sometimes
i think it helps to to hear it again so
we can understand just how
incoherent it was he says i'm going to
say something outrageous
i have never been particularly poor at
calculating how to get things done in
the united states senate
so the best way to get something done if
you if you hold near and dear to to you
that you
uh um like to be able to anyway
i we're gonna get a lot done
now if this was the first time that
biden had
stumbled in this way we might just
assume that he didn't have enough coffee
that morning or he was especially
distracted for whatever reason but
this kind of thing happens all the time
not slips of the tongue but divergences
into full-on incoherence and it's
getting worse
remember it's only a few days ago that
biden proved himself incapable of safely
navigating a flight of steps
now he's standing on national television
claiming that he entered the senate in
the year 1901
it now seems to be a question not of
whether camilla harris will be the one
finishing out biden's term
but when exactly she will take over
another question
if biden becomes entirely incapacitated
assuming he isn't already at that point
will we be informed of that when will we
be informed
how can we have any confidence that
they'll tell us the truth about biden's
condition in the future
if they clearly aren't telling us the
truth right now
all of the ingredients for a
catastrophic constitutional crisis
are present they were already baked into
the cake the moment that a 78 year old
man was inaugurated
and this this ought to be the last time
we allow that to happen
in a sane country laws and amendments
will be passed to ensure that this does
not happen again
quite simply it is madness to allow a
man like this
to become president of the united states
leaving aside my personal and political
feelings about joe biden
i mean i wouldn't want him to be
president even if he was 30 years
younger admittedly but
there could never be a good reason to
put a person so
old into the highest and most important
political office in the land
even if biden were not already showing
clear signs of mental regression
it would still be the case that one in
seven people over the age of 70
have dementia one in seven
the percentages only get higher as you
get older and it certainly can't help
your case
if you happen to be in one of the most
physically and mentally demanding jobs
in existence
about 2 million people with dementia in
this country are age 85 or older
but there are only 7 million people
total in that age bracket
what this means is that mental
deterioration is
is very common for older people and only
becomes
more common the older they get if a man
is elected president
at 78 again even pretending that he he
has his wits fully about him
at the point that he's elected there's a
very significant probability that he
will lose his mind
before his first term is completed it is
very
very probable if he does not you know
lose only his mind he may likely lose
his life in the intervening years as
well the life expectancy
for a 78 year old man is nine years
okay uh wait so if you're at 78
most likely you've got nine years left
if not less
and that again doesn't factor in the
unique stresses and burdens of the job
they get to that life expectancy of nine
years for 78 year old people
but they're measuring this based on the
majority of 78 year old people who are
retired and are living lives of
relative leisure
we don't allow anyone under the age of
35 to run for president and i've rarely
heard anyone complain about
that age restriction in fact i've never
heard anyone complain about it
never yet the risk inherent
in having a decrepit president are much
much greater than the risks
of having a spry young 32 year old in
office
if we're ruling out the 32 year old on
the basis of his age alone
it doesn't make any sense that we refuse
to rule people out on the other end of
the age spectrum
there should be an upper age limit on
the presidency just as there is on
a lower limit we could be generous and
we could talk about what the age limit
should be
um we could be generous we could put the
cap at 75.
uh you could go younger you make an
argument for younger
and this would give every american 40
years
between 35 and 75 to take their shot at
the presidency
if they desire can't get it done in four
decades
it wasn't meant to be go home and play
with your grandchildren it'll be better
for you it'll be better for the country
it'll be better for your grandchildren
i realize this age limit will never be
put in place i mean this is this is um
not ever going to happen because it
would have to be put in place by
politicians
who are willingly limiting their own
chance to become president
there are maybe a handful maybe a
handful of politicians in dc
with the integrity to support such a
self-limiting policy
and we need a lot more than a handful to
get this done um that's the reason it
won't happen
but it's a bad reason is there any good
reason
to keep the cap off of the presidency
is there any ethically or logically
sound argument
for allowing 80 year olds and 90 year
olds
the chance to take office even as we
deny
30 year olds the same chance i can't see
what the argument would be
i've never heard anyone present it yet
in my experience even now
the the idea of putting an upper age
limit on the presidency is relatively
unpopular
we're watching our president fall apart
mentally and physically right in front
of us
but that hasn't convinced many americans
that there's necessarily anything wrong
with putting a very elderly person in
the white house
perhaps that shouldn't be surprising if
the last year has taught us anything
it's that we as a culture are in denial
about our own mortality and the
inevitability of our own death
this with biden the fact that we have a
78 year old president
perhaps ironically is a symptom of that
this is something only a culture in
denial about
death and mortality could be stupid
enough
to put a 78 year old man in office
we like to say things like uh age is
just a number and i've heard that about
biden so many times when i brought this
up
people say to me page is just a number
no it isn't what kind of silly nonsense
is that
it's a lot more than a number it is a
reality
about you physically age represents many
significant things
one of them is proximity to death
as you get older you get closer and
closer to the end of your life
that's the reality that process of
getting closer to the end of your life
the process of
dying is merciless
and unrelenting and it's not fun
as your mind and your body progressively
degenerate
there are certain realities right that
come with being mortal creatures many of
those realities are not
especially enjoyable this is one such
unenjoyable reality we all die the older
we get
the closer we come to our deaths the
closer we come to our death
the more that our bodies and minds
disintegrate
this is a true story but it's not the
one we prefer to tell ourselves
our preferred story is one where age has
no meaning
our bodies and brains will never fail us
we will never die
and anyone of any age is capable of
doing anything and holding any job
and to say otherwise is to display
bigotry and ageism ageism and
and a severe lack of optimism on top of
it
now i confess i prefer that story too
the one where we don't die and our
bodies and minds never fail us and we
get to live forever
i love that story but it's a fantasy
and in the long run it's better to live
in reality
and better to vote there too i think
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to five headlines i want
to tell you about our sponsors
my pillow you know i have this uh
opinion that appears to be controversial
where you know i i think that the most
important ingredient in a sandwich is
the bread
that's really what pulls it all together
you can't have a good sandwich without
good bread it's not the meat it's the
bread that matters
well with sleeping maybe this is less
controversial the most important
ingredient is the pillow
more than anything else it comes down to
the pillow if you don't have a good
pillow
then you're not going to get a good
night's sleep and that's why you need
my pillow my pillow products don't go
flat you can wash you can dry them
as many times as you want and they
maintain your their shape and you better
be washing them
you dirty dirty disgusting people and
best of all they're made in the usa
and if you don't have a my pillow or you
know someone who doesn't have them now
is the time to get one because for a
limited time
my pillow is offering their premium my
pillows for the lowest price ever you
can get a queen size premium my pillow
which is usually for 69.98 for only
29.98 that's a 40
savings that you get kings are only five
dollars more now is the time to buy i
don't put it off anymore
you're not only getting the lowest price
ever but they're the best
gifts ever 29.98 for a queen size
premium my pillow so now's the time to
do it
go to mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square they'll
there you'll find not only this amazing
offer but also discounts on
all my pillow products including the the
giza dream bed sheets the my pillow
mattress topper
and my pillow towel cells or call
800-651-1148 and use promo code
dailywire
all right well i have this from the
daily mail it says a program to give 500
monthly checks to low-income families of
color in oakland california has been
criticized for explicitly excluding the
10
000 white residents living in poverty in
the city
you think the lottery system funded by
private philanthropists
will see the no strings attached checks
go to households with an annual income
of less than 59 000
if they have at least one child the
other half of the 500
checks will go to those earning under 30
000
so under 59 000 with one child is
poverty now
apparently um according to data from an
oakland equity indicators report
cited by officials to justify favoring
people of color white households
um earn about three times that of
african-american ones
the same report states that around eight
percent of the city's white residents
approximately ten thousand people live
in poverty
this is the excuse they're giving and
this is how weak the
of course it this is racism and uh the
excuses for racism are always weak
i've never heard a good excuse to be
racist this is this is no exception
so their excuse is we're only giving
this
to um to poor
black families and not white families
because most of the poor families are
black
well okay but there are poor white
families
so for those specific cases
why are they out of luck why don't they
get anything
there might be fewer of them but if
you're a
poor white family living in oakland the
fact that
there aren't as many other poor white
families what does that do for you how
does that help you
but is it is it emotional solace where
you can
look around and say well you know at
least my race generally speaking is
doing pretty well
sorry kids i know you're not gonna eat
tonight but uh you should know
the white family down the street they're
doing real well i hope that makes you
feel better
of course not this this is
out and out in your face racism and uh
this this also
it's kind of helpful because this shows
us not only what racism looks like
and that's not reverse racism but plain
old racism no such thing as reverse
racism racism and racism
but this also shows us what this is what
systemic racism
looks like systemic institutional racism
okay um this this is what it is
a very helpful demonstration for us
and so when we hear about alleged
systemic racism
against black people if it doesn't look
kind of like this it's not systemic
racism
what are the two hallmarks here one
we are in this case a specific race of
people are being explicitly singled out
for a disadvantage they are being
disadvantaged
explicitly based on their race it is
right there it's in writing
if you're a white family you don't get
this that's how we know it's racist
and we know it's systemic because it's
literally a system they're putting a
system in place
to give these benefits to some families
and not others and the ones who don't
get it it's because of their race
that is systemic racism
now what you notice about
really all of the claims um
in modern day of systemic racism against
black people what you notice is that
you don't have both of those factors
together and usually you don't even have
one because
the left will point to something and say
that's systemic racism against black
people
yet you don't yet yet black people are
not being explicitly singled out
so for example they'll look at
incarceration rates and they'll say you
know there are more black people being
sent to prison
but there's no law saying that if you're
black
you're gonna you're gonna face a worse
punishment
there's nothing there's nothing in the
system saying if you're if you're this
race this is the punishment if you're
that race here's the punishment over
here
that would be racism obviously and
systemic
but that's not the case here
there's a there's an inequality in the
outcome
um in terms of how many people end up in
prison depending on race
but that's not that's not because
there's a there's a law in place saying
that if you're
this race you have to go to prison for
longer or you're going to get this and
that
a punishment
now you can you can theorize that yeah
although
although it doesn't say that uh really
underneath all of this there's still
racism and it's buried down there
somewhere
okay that's your theory and now you
gotta prove that you have to
you can't you can't simply notice
any quality of outcome among races in a
particular area and
state assert that it's because of racism
without proving it
in a case like this in oakland i don't
have to prove anything it's right there
in writing
if you're white you don't get it
that's systemic racism for you all right
um
from the new york post it says maya
pancetto who the woman dubbed
soho karen after she falsely accused a
black teenager of swiping her cell phone
is now being sued by the boy's family
over the high profile incident
we talked about that on this show um
jazz trumpeter keon harold his 15 year
old son and the teen's mom on wednesday
filed the suit against poncetto
and a worker at the arlo soho hotel
where the december 26 violent incident
of racial profiling occurred
you remember pancetto was caught on
video claiming that teen
keon harold jr took her phone and then
tried to tackle him in the lobby of the
hudson street hotel
um and turns out he didn't take the
phone and he was being falsely accused
um
now she's being sued on
a number of things let's see the
manhattan supreme court suit accuses
ponsetto and hotel worker chad nathan of
assault battery
intentional infliction of emotional
distress and false imprisonment
and the hotel of negligence and
negligent hiring
all right this family they're really
milking this thing for all
all it's worth i i i don't doubt it was
it's uh
it's a disturbing and upsetting thing
when a crazy woman accost you in the
hotel lobby
you know and i but i think for most
people you have an experience like that
and i've encountered crazy people before
um in in my life and usually what
happens is you have this encounter with
a crazy person and then
you know you go about you live the rest
of your life and it becomes a story that
you tell
sometimes um when you know at a
at a party or something uh becomes a
funny story
i think that's most people but this
family they said no of course we're
gonna we're gonna use this
um this this unpleasant encounter nobody
was injured or harmed in any way
um this woman was totally in the wrong
of course but unplug but she's she's
mentally unstable it's very clear
so an unpleasant encounter with a
mentally unstable woman in which nobody
was harmed in any way whatsoever
we're going to use this and we're going
to get rich off of it and that's what
they're trying to do
and uh they're they're throwing the
hotel worker into it also what did he do
he just happened to be there it's not
his fault
you know he's not equipped to deal with
a crazy person losing her mind
he's working at a hotel he's not a you
know
he's not a crisis counselor at a mental
institution but we're supposed to yeah i
guess we're supposed to
still see the family as a victim
uh that warrants you know
making millions of dollars false
imprisonment
how she imprisoned the kid now
in what way all right number three uh
sesame street has introduced
some new muppet characters um these are
we're told they're black muppets
although not really because
puppets don't have a race but uh and
their job is to teach kids about race
and racism
and cbs has the report on that let's
listen
sesame street is introducing two new
black muppets as part of its initiative
to tackle racism
things on the outside like our skin
color our
hair texture our noses
our mouths and eyes make us who we are
many people call this race but even
though we look different
we're all part of the human race
five-year-old wes and his father elijah
sat down with elmo
to talk about race and what it means
the things on the outside make us who we
are
that is the opposite of what i was told
growing up
that's the opposite of what sesame
watching sesame street as a kid
it's the opposite of what the message
always was
literally the opposite we were told it's
that was what was draining
drilled into your head as a kid uh
what's on the outside doesn't make you
who you are it's
it's what's on the inside that matters
right that was the message
and now they've completely flipped it
around
and said no never mind you know what
actually it is all your identity is skin
deep it turns out
this is from sesame workshop they have
they are explaining what they're doing
here
and this is what they're saying quote
sesame workshop has always stood for
diversity inclusion equity and kindness
as a trusted source for families we have
a responsibility to speak out for racial
justice and empower families
to have conversations about race and
identity with their children at a young
age
no actually you don't have a
responsibility to speak out for racial
justice
you are a show about puppets and a giant
bird
so you you you don't have that
responsibility at all
your responsibility if you have any it's
to teach kids the abcs and the one two
threes
that's pretty much the extent of it
it continues the work to dismantle
racism begins by helping children
understand what racism is and how it
hurts and impacts people
sadly today's announcement comes at a
time of racial and social discord when
many families are in need of support and
talking to their
children about racism and that's what
they need a puppet for
we're proud to reaffirm our coming
together commitment to racial justice
which will be woven into the new
sesame sesame workshop content for years
to come
um you know what you should
tell your kids about race and racism
especially if they're if they're at an
age where they're watching
sesame street if they're at the sesame
street age which is what like
three to i don't know eight or nine
you know you should tell them about race
and racism
nothing you should tell them nothing
about it
you shouldn't bother them with it you
should let them be kids
let them be children
instead of foisting all of this on them
that's what you should do that is
that's what you would do if you actually
wanted kids
to live in some kind of racial harmony
uh with with other kids and to and to
not really
worry about the races of other kids and
just if you wanted kids to to get along
with each other
and um worry about what really matters
and all of that
that's what you would do you wouldn't
bother them with this
but of course the people behind this
critical race theorists and so on that's
not what they want
they want despite what we're told here
what we're told here is they want to get
rid of division and discord that's ex
that's
that's not at all that's the opposite is
true they they want to sow division and
discord
and they want to do it at a young age
and they want our kids to define
themselves by what's on the outside and
to define each other about what's on the
outside
and to split off into little groups and
have their own tribes that's what they
want
and the sad thing is that that's
probably what they're going to get
it'll probably succeed okay another
viral we got a couple videos i have to
show
none of them that i really that i really
want to but i have to unfortunately
so another viral tick tock video to show
you this one from a woman
ranting about anti-masters and the pro
maskers love this one
it went viral online and here's what she
has to say let's watch
to the people who refuse to wear masks
at this point
we are done with you it's not up for
discussion you can't come in
get the [ __ ] out no you don't get to
explain your point of view
it's irrelevant you can't go topless or
shoeless in a store and now you can't go
maskless why because we're trying to
ruin your freedoms
no because the rules have changed
because reality has changed
no one cares if you don't believe in
asymptomatic spread no one gives a [ __ ]
that you're just there for a couple
things
it doesn't matter if you don't think
it's fair that is how it is
a functioning civilized society has
rules you don't get to pick and choose
which ones you want to follow because
you wear your seat belt drive the speed
limit
and wear this piece of fabric over your
nose and mouth if you're going out in
public
the end off and if you still think it's
not such a big deal then go volunteer at
a hospital or a morgue because those
employees are
absolutely freaking exhausted because
people like you keep making everyone
sick and their jobs harder okay
honestly pull your [ __ ] together
are they exhausted you know they've been
making
music videos and tick tock videos this
whole time in fact we'll have one of
those coming up in here in a minute
this uh this is the whole argument right
what you just heard there and
it's it's it's really funny to me to
hear this from the left now where they
say
the society has rules this is the they
used to position themselves as the
rebels in the counter culture and now
they're the ones screaming society has
rules damn it
obey the rules again
going back to when i was a kid growing
up i remember uh
bumper stickers that would in the
barber sticker slogan was question
everything
and you see that on cars a lot a lot of
the
people now who are wearing the mask and
paranoid about it
i told you a few days ago the guy when i
got on the elevator without a mask and
he and he
went storming off whimpering and afraid
i bet you that that guy when he was
younger he had one of those bumper
stickers question everything
the people that had the question
everything bumper sticker
now this is their approach they went
from question everything
to obey the rules damn it don't ask
questions
we don't care about your questions your
point of view
do it because we say so that's it
we're not going to tell you why
that's why i i appreciate that the pro
masters are sharing that video
and i'm glad that they are because that
is you so you saw there there's no
no argument presented there's no reason
given
she's not coming with statistics for
example
showing us or percentages or data
showing us how likely it actually is
that an asymptomatic person will spread
covet
not bothering with that
in fact she's not going to show us she
doesn't want us to see those numbers not
going to help her case
instead it's go along with the program
shut up
and and do it because we say so
these are the these these are the
counter culture rebel counter culture
rebels this is what they've this is what
has become of them
quite sad to see and i was never a big
fan of bumper stickers but
and i never had the question everything
bumper sticker but i like that one
that is actually as far as bumper
sticker slogans go
that's a good one that's about as good
as a bumper sticker slogan's gonna get
actually question everything you should
that doesn't mean that you should walk
around every day unsure
and never drawing any conclusions
whatsoever
but any time you you you face a new idea
a new proposition uh a new policy that's
put in place
a law whatever it is your first
thing should be to question it just and
the question is very simple
why why why are we doing this why is
this in place
why is this claim being made yeah
question but not anymore
don't question everything accept
everything and shut up all right
speaking of masks
cbs news has this story about
a new kind of mask that you can wear
while eating
um and this is a problem now i've been
on planes and uh
and and even restaurants where i've seen
maybe you've seen as well
a little bit less common in restaurants
but i see this on planes all the time
where people they they'll wear the full
mask and they'll pull the mask down
i was watching someone yesterday this
this weekend on a plane doing this
they had a a bag of peanuts
and they had the mask on they would pull
the mask down put one peanut in the
mouth
pull the mask up chew and swallow mask
down another peanut and just that whole
process
uh but there's a solution now and let's
play this video here here's the solution
you see there the mask just there's a
just the mask over the nose
this is a new thing it's it's just been
introduced i don't know if you can get
it online yet if you're excited maybe
um so the idea is that you're gonna wear
two masks and one is a normal mask over
the mouth that knows and then you're
gonna wear a second mask
or maybe this will be your third because
you're wearing two regular masks and the
third one
where it's the mask just over the nose
and then when you want to eat you take
off the two bigger masks and you have
only the mask over the nose and you can
eat what i love about that
is that it looks exactly like a clown
nose
and that is it you know pardon the punt
but it's a little bit too on the nose in
fact
because yes you do if that that is what
a clown would do
so if you're worried you can always do
that wear the mask over the nose
unless as i said you have anything like
dignity self-respect in which case
in which case you'll take the mask off
and eat like a normal human being
okay finally i got to play this too i
know we're playing video after video
here but i gotta i i have to do this
um
you know that i i have no choice but to
do it because the boomers
they won't stop making music videos for
tick-tock
which means if they're not going to stop
making them i can't stop showing them
i have no this is my responsibility
sesame street has their responsibility
to talk about race this is my
responsibility
to play you the music videos that
boomers make for tick-tock
and here's the latest one put together
by a doctor's office
and here's what they've got let's watch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whether it's the gunner or whether it's
staying alive
[Music]
remember these these medical
professionals are exhausted we just
heard that from the mask lady
they're exhausted they've been working
so hard i bet they are exhausted after
shooting this music video it looks
pretty exhausting
i'm just trying to imagine going to the
doctor's office for some legitimate
ailment
ailment and you walk in and then you you
find the doctor
in a wig and in a disco outfit
um with a big prop syringe dancing
through the hallways what are you gonna
think
you're gonna think this guy's a
psychotic which and your your assumption
will be true
so there it is i had i did my part and i
showed it to you and uh
we'll we'll try to move on as best we
can let's go to reading youtube comments
jesse richard says
matt seems like the kind of stern father
that still adheres to middle school
rules like
i called it and dares if you've been
banned from the show i'd imagine all it
would take is a triple dog dare for him
to unban you
and matt would be obliged to do it this
is
so on point you have distilled me down
to my essence right here because that
you that is
actually exactly right i understand
myself better now after reading that
youtube comment
a stern father who adheres to middle
school rules that is that is
true that's that's who i am
stern father but also immature
in some really strange ways and it makes
for an odd combination
um i do for example my my kids i have
them
to decide who has to do what chore i
have them do rock paper scissors for
that that's my idea i tell them that's
the requirement
to do rock paper scissors those kinds of
things i i still i believe in those
worlds rock paper scissors
call it shotgun all that i live by that
i will die by it um let's see
the other comment says matt you're
always ranting and raving about cats and
dogs you should get a bird
they're neat they're clever they can fly
and some even talk
you would like them first of all the
last thing i need is another
talking creature in the house
the fact that they can talk is not a
positive for me that's not a selling
point
would you say well here's here's an
animal that uh
uh you know they got all the
disadvantages of a cat and dog but also
they make more noise
oh gee let me go get one then i will say
though i saw a study yesterday
well i didn't actually read the study
but i saw the headline and the headline
was
that according to the study birds give
people as much happiness as money
that's the claim anyway and i can see
how that be true
if the bird is bringing you money but
outside of that i don't see it
finally matt now that you've effectively
banished
all of your viewers except me do i get a
prize
asking for a handout that's what you're
doing you know what that gets you
banned from the show of course we've
been talking a lot about the
constitution and gun rights this week
and it's it's always an extremely
important topic
um never more so than than right now in
this moment
and conservatives you know we say we
love the constitution we say we we care
so much about
about gun rights and all the rights of
the constitution affords us yet
how many of us have actually taken the
time to study it how many of us stand
ready to defend it well my friends over
at constitutioncoach.com have a lot of
great programs for equipping citizens to
defend liberty by studying and living
out the constitution
i just experienced i've been telling you
about the constitutional defense course
i came away from that you know not only
understanding
more about the constitution but also
understanding a lot more about firearms
and how to use them
being more comfortable with them being
able to defend myself and my family
that's a responsibility that
i believe that i have as a as an
american as a man to defend myself and
my family
and i feel much more able to do that now
you can do this too you get an amazing
combination of intellectual ammunition
and live classes with rick
with rick green america's constitution
coach and then also get physical
training at the premier
firearms training facility in the nation
all in the same course you get to join
hundreds of other patriots from across
the nation for a time of learning
training and fellowship with like-minded
people
don't just get a gun you got to learn
how to use it go to
constitutioncoach.com
with all the instability in the u.s
these days this training is more
important than ever
rick and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but it
will fill up fast so visit
constitutioncoach.com today and watch my
video there to find out more about how
you can be
a part of this one-of-a-kind training
constitution coach
well get excited because tonight is the
premiere of episode two of candace daily
wire's new talk show hosted by candace
owens it's coming um
yet again we had the first episode last
week this is episode number two it's
gonna be great the show will
live stream over at dailywire.com at 9
pm eastern 8 pm central
featuring special guests john rich
bryson gray
brandon tatum and daily wire's own
michael knowles so tune in
9 pm eastern 8 pm central if you're not
a member yet go to dailywire.com
subscribe and get 25 off and with a new
membership with code
candice that's dailywire.com subscribe
and get 25 off
with code candace now let's get to our
daily cancellation
so we have another reverse cancellation
this is where i'm i'm being canceled but
at the last minute in a dramatic turn of
events i managed to evade my cancelers
and turn the cancellation back around on
them a highly specialized and
devastating maneuver
today it begins with news out of georgia
we'll read now from the daily wire says
georgia governor brian kemp
signed the republican-backed election
integrity act of 2021
or sb 202 into law thursday as
democratic lawmakers protested the bill
the legislation seeks to tighten up
elections and reduce fraud by
enforcing conformity across the state
amping up voter id
restricting drop boxes and expanding
in-person voting among additional
election-related overhauls
the bill's provisions add id
requirements for absentee by mail
ballots
would georgians return their ballots
they'll be required to use a form of
identification
identification to verify who they are as
noted by npr this change quote replaces
the controversial method that as
election workers match signatures and
applications and ballot envelopes
with those on file sp202 also expands
in-person voting access kemp's signing
of the bill
sparked protests from democratic
representatives democratic
representative park
cannon was detained by georgia state
patrol after she made it to an entrance
of the governor's office
she was escorted out of the building in
handcuffs but it remains unclear if
cannon will be charged with anything
all right now we must say first of all
thank you to the police officers who
arrested the insurrectionist park cannon
she was trying to interfere with the
democratic process and in so doing she
represented a profound threat to our
democracy and our way of life
truly march 25th 2021 we'll live forever
in our memories as that as the day
that a violent insurrectionist nearly
destroyed
our whole system of government if not
for the efforts of our brave uniformed
officers
and of the steely determination of
governor kemp who is no doubt
traumatized by the whole affair
maybe he can do an instagram live video
and tell us about it
more to the point as for the bill itself
i consider it to be a good start
many on the left are saying that it will
prevent people from voting it'll do no
such thing
there's no reason why anyone who wants
to vote should be stopped from voting
by a bill like this but personally
as you know if you listen to this show i
am unapologetically in favor of stopping
people from voting
the accusation is that we on the right
want to disenfranchise people
the thing is what i'll say to that is
yeah i do
not all people let me be clear i don't
want to disagree with everyone
just most people like many millions
i think that one of the greatest crises
are our system of government
faces perhaps the crisis is that the
course of our country and our political
system is decided by hordes of
people and a large percentage of whom
have absolutely no idea what they're
doing why they're doing it
what's going on who they're actually
voting for or anything else
that's why i favor testing perhaps other
requirements
as well to ensure that that only those
americans who are
informed and competent are able to vote
as i've explained many times
voting is not a god-given right it's a
privilege and it's a privilege that
should only be exercised
by those who are most fit to do so
i take that position because i care
about our country and our system
i would submit that if you want to
encourage the hordes
of ignoramuses who have no idea what
they're doing if you want to encourage
them
to stumble into the voting booth or not
even stumble and just send in a ballot
randomly making a selection with no
basis of knowledge or information
underlying that selection you are the
one who has no respect for our system
our way of life our democracy
now i realize that my view is seen as
heresy in our country today and it's
very upsetting
for people to hear it but you know the
good thing for me is that i don't really
give a damn what anyone thinks or how
they feel so
i'll continue saying it i made this case
yet again on twitter last
night in response to the georgia bill
and lots of people were upset as you
expect
the primary complaint or accusation
is that i'm racist and of course that
that's
anytime people disagree with you that's
going to be their primary thing that
they say in response no matter what your
opinion is they're going to call it
racist
but many of the people in the outrage
mob and this happens whenever i raise
this subject um accuse me of racism for
saying that only competent and informed
people should be voting
but calling my position on that subject
racist is
frankly the most racist thing i've ever
heard
why would you assume that a test
measuring basic voter competency would
have the effect of disenfranchising
minorities
what tell me why you assume that strikes
me as a deeply
bigoted assumption and let's remember
it's your assumption not mine
i have no opinion about how the
different races would perform
on a test like this i have no preference
either i don't care what your color your
skin is when you go to vote doesn't
matter to me
i only care that you're informed and
engaged
that's it i think we could
change our country for the better
dramatically we could we could
we could have a almost a utopia maybe
not quite a utopia but we need as close
as we possibly can get to it
if you just made this simple change of
weeding out
the ignorant people who have no business
in the voting booth
any race it doesn't matter i also
believe that anyone of any race is
perfectly capable
of being informed and engaged especially
these days because the internet gives us
all all gives us all the access to all
the information we need
you carry around in your pocket every
day a portal
to to all of the accumulated knowledge
and information mankind has to offer you
have it
in your pocket on this device there's no
excuse to be uninformed in the year 2021
anyone can know anything
now the fact that we use this thing
not to make ourselves informed but to
make ourselves dumber
well that's our choice it doesn't have
to be that way
it takes only minimal effort to become
informed and anyone is capable of
expending that effort
those who can't be bothered shouldn't
vote
those who assume that racial minorities
are less capable or less interested in
informing themselves
are again racist this is the bigotry of
low expectations on steroids it's
degrading it's insulting
it's like if you're a man and you ask
another guy to hand you a jar of pickles
and right before he hands it to you he
says here let me get this open for you
there you go
that's not a backhanded favor it's just
a backhand
and this is how white leftists treat
minorities and they do this while
calling for equality
and accusing their opposition of
interfering with the very equality that
they
oppose i believe in total equality in
the voting booth
that is every competent adult should be
able to vote
black white whatever i don't care
however that cookie crumbles
whatever the racial makeup of the
electorate ends up being after we test
for competency competency
well that's how it is if it ends up that
i can't vote because as my critics
accuse me
i'm advocating for competent voting
while being an incompetent [ __ ] myself
so be it if that's the case i'm not
playing favorites
i hold everyone to the same standard if
you don't
then i'd say that you're the one with a
bigotry problem
you're also the one who i'm afraid to
say
is canceled and we'll leave it there for
today and for this week
hope you have a great weekend talk to
you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 21. hey everybody this is andrew
clavin host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin